Okay, here's a simple CUDA program that'll illustrate these ideas.
So we're going to launch 16 blocks,
and each one's going to have a single thread running,
and it's going to run a trivial kernel that just prints, "Hello world! I'm a thread in block."
And then in the main, we're going to do nothing more than launch that kernel.
You need this call cudaDeviceSynchronize to make sure
that these print f's flush and then we'll print, "That's all."
So before we run this, here's a quick quiz.
How many different outputs do you think different runs of this program can produce?
Is it 1?
16 possible different outputs?
2 to the 16th possible different outputs?
Or 21 trillion possible outputs?